-Our next guest is a talente
actress, comedian, and write
you know from shows
like "Happy Endings,"
"Black Monday," and "Marry Me.
Her book, "The Wreckage of
My Presence" is available now.
Please welcome back to the sho
our friend Casey Wilson.
Hello, Casey. How are you?
-Hi, Seth! I'm good.
I'm so happy to be here. Hello
-Hello. Congratulations.
A couple of great
accomplishments.
The main one, let's be honest,
"New York Times" best-seller
And I want to talk
more about that.
But I heard tell
you were equally happy
about this accomplishment.
You made "People's"
Beauties of Every age.
-That's right.
-Let's just see
if we can find you there.
Talk about --
Talk about this moment
being recognized for your beauty
by "People."
-Okay. So I will say I think
this is a greater achievement,
if I may, than "The New York
Times" best-seller list.
You know, you can't campaign
for this, but I am --
Look, "People" magazine has said
I'm the most beautiful
40-year-old in the world.
And that's just how it is.
And I just want to apologize
you know, formally
to all 40-year-olds
who weren't this lucky.
But I will be
representing all of us.
-Did you feel overlooked las
year as a beautiful 39-year-old?
-I absolutely did.
I was angry. I was upset.
But I decided to come back
stronger this year
and honestly,
I'm campaigning now for 41
-Right.
-Yeah.
-Well, that would
be heartbreaking
if you don't get it, 'caus
that would just be an indictment
of what has happened to your
beauty over course of the year
-Yes, and so quickly, I woul
fall. I would fall from grace.
So I just I want
everyone to know,
if you have any ties
to "People" magazine --
And, look, no one else seems
to care about this "award,
and they told me
it's not an award.
But isn't it?
-I think it is.
And I think it's very
well deserved.
I want to ask this.
I know you've talked
a lot in the past.
You enjoy spending time in bed
and in the bath.
-That's right.
-And you actually found ou
about your "New York Times
best-seller status
in which of the two?
Where were you?
-Okay. So, this is hard to say
and it was midday.
I was -- Just gotten out o
the bath and, believe it or not,
was about to get into the be
to take a nap
when I checked my phone.
My husband was a bit disturbed
You know, we have two kids
and I work full time,
as to how I was able to do those
two things midday.
But I just love -- I'm a bat
person and a bed person.
I love to eat in the bed,
and I love to have friends
receive people in the bath
maybe on a little stool.
We have to multi-task, Seth.
You can get a lot done in there.
You can put a laptop on a caddy.
-This past year,
a lot of people thrived
in both the bed and the bath
Did you find yourself to be well
prepared for what beset us all
-No one was more prepared
for this pandemic than I was
It was such a smooth transitio
as someone who needs
to be submerged in water
with a down comforter
over her at all times than me.
It was beautiful.
-Your father features heavil
in your book.
And we've talk about Paul
on the show before.
And you have pointed people --
Or I should say you've suggested
that people enjoy
his Twitter account.
-That's right.
-This is an active
Twitter account,
and these are some
of his finest tweets.
-Okay.
-"Wound up not running."
-[ Laughs ]
He just wound up not, yeah
-This one's a good one.
"Dinner."
-[ Laughs ]
They're very kind of
avant garde.
-This is one for anybody
who is thinking,
maybe logged
onto Twitter saying,
"Hey, you know, I should
call my old friend Paul,"
and they would be upset
to find out
that he's busy for 40 minutes.
-[ Laughs ]
There was a bit of an incident
I think, in his brain
of, like, "Am I texting
or am I tweeting?"
And that got a bit --
-Yes.
-You know.
-There is also the idea
of, you know, sub-tweeting
where you don't specifically
call out the person,
but it's obvious
who you're talking about.
-Okay.
-Although I don't know
if he's doing it right, either
'cause this --
Who knows who this is for?
-[ Laughs ] Very boring!
I don't know if that's
about this interview.
I don't know, you know?
-Well, no, it can't be.
It was from 2010.
Something in July,
summer of 2010, Paul --
By the way, I can't believ
your dad's been on Twitter now
for over a decade.
That's an accomplishment.
-He's also --
-Oh, there he is! Hi, Paul
Nice to see you again.
-Hey. Quit making fun of me.
-Okay. Please.
This is so upsetting, Seth
I'm coming to everyone fro
Delaware on a family vacation,
and I have about 50 family
members just gathered around
-Well, he definitely knows
his best angle for Zoom.
[ Laughter ]
Just real, real close,
top corner of the frame.
I want to talk about your book
which is wonderful.
We'll be right back with mor
from Casey Wilson after this